old times sake I mean how you feeling
and I watchin day well I don't know you
do but you kind of sacrifice yourself no
no this is probably greater yeah but
tell me did me no slams them so that the
negotiations starts again and they have
a unity in the girl I want to end with
your position they didn't need that you
step down well I'm sorry you may very
well say this at one comment do you feel
relieved that I wanna say but it's
always a relief to get rid of minister
finals it is a very big lump on one's
conscience in one shoulders isn't it
everything is Harry Chancellor being
tough day it was part of the course it
was what was soon down why hey ok
interpret it well now you know the act
of interpretation is the salt of the
earth what are you gonna do now what's
the next time I'm going to rest for a
day and then start working again of you
know i'm a member of parliament in a
government which is hell-bent on making
this thing work and you're still applies
you're surprised if need be on this
process inevitable thank you